all right sean yes sean uh where'd you
go where are you from originally uh i
grew up all over the place uh i ended up
i would say in connecticut
if uh if you if i have a place to call
home it's connecticut
my father was in the air force during
vietnam so i was all over the place as a
kid like a new place every other year
type of deal
um
when he retired after 14 years
it was connecticut and that's where i
kind of stayed
uh
i ended up doing boarding school for two
years before i was
formally asked to leave
um
i i did end up getting into college and
i went to college and uh and got my
girlfriend pregnant i graduated and uh
and got married and
uh put on a suit and tie you know for a
good long time and thought i had my [ __ ]
together for a while and i did
and uh and my ex-wife decided to uh
have an affair and
take my kid and my house and my truck
and my dog and my
self-worth and
everything she could take
my 401k she took it all and uh left me
with very little i i uh
want me just to get right into it please
okay and uh that's what we do here from
there you know i had screwed around as a
young man a lot i i spent my high school
years and my college years on the
grateful dead tour doing everything
including heroin
and uh
um uh mdma before it was illegal and and
everything uh
we actually you know we had a
perforation machine we were making lsd
this goes but before before you get into
all this what was your childhood like it
was a good childhood it was
it was fair yeah it was uh you know i i
have still a really good mother
who uh almost died of kovid uh
interestingly enough as you know this
type of time goes by
uh they told us three times in three
different nights that she was probably
going to die
and she's in connecticut my own father
couldn't visit her they're both about
80.
but uh they're good parents you know my
dad
uh
is is a good man he's uh he's just not
like me you know i had dreadlocks and a
nose ring and he was a colonel by the
time he was 34.
so we did not see eye to eye you know
the sheep of the family um
in a way yeah my brother uh has been a
schoolteacher for 20
seven years he's a year younger than i
am
uh
you know i had a good job for a while
but then
so so i get divorced and i ended up
taking a job in new york city which was
a good job also
and uh
but new york city is where
i learned to be bad so it was not long
before a friend of mine
got out of prison and needed a place to
stay
and i hadn't spoken to him in a while
and i said come stay with me another
great idea
and uh
before i knew it i'm wearing a suit and
tie to work but i i it was an out
outside sales job so i'd go to work in
the morning
uh show up turn on my computer
go out get a bundle of heroin
um
get high go do a little work
uh just had to make your nut every month
and i was well taken care of
um my job was easy at the time
um
i won't get into what the work was it's
just
you're a functional addict functioning
addict oh yeah i mean heroin absolutely
um
until i wasn't functioning anymore and
and i ran out of money uh but i
that is because
honestly i started smoking crack along
with it and that really took me down
quick so my best friend gary's kicking
my door
and threatens to call my mom and i'm
quiet like a church mouse because
i just rather not deal with reality
and two days later my mother who had
never been to my house in new york shows
up at my door
uh
i never saw that apartment again i went
to rehab for the first time
i was 28 years old
um
i stayed clean for
a couple years i went to a.a every day
and uh not knowing what else to do i was
told do this and i did it and it worked
for a while
and
i took a really hard job uh actually
working for my dad who who but at this
time was running
he owns a lumber yard in connecticut a
big one
and so i'm opening the place at 5 30 in
the morning closing it at seven working
six days a week thinking i got my [ __ ]
together and for a while i did
there's out east they call them package
stores it's the same thing as a liquor
store out here there was a package store
right across the street from where i
worked
and just one day after work i just
wanted a beer honestly i i hadn't even
had a beer in five years
and uh
within one week i was shooting heroin
and smoking crack again
so
i was about to get married again i lost
the woman
i i blew everything apart again within a
matter of probably a year and a half
lost the job with my dad
um
i it ended up in jail
uh
and i couldn't get out for a while this
time i've been arrested a few times
before and now yeah this is the second
this is the second woman you've done
this with um
i was married and didn't really have an
issue with her as far as like jail went
or anything like that we were married i
drank too much that was about it
um but
this was your second relationship that
went south yes this is my second like
big time really like like was gonna get
married she had kids that were
considering me their stepdad type this
was like a big deal moved into her house
and uh and i blew all that up one day
she was like where's the money and i
just showed her my arms and they were
all beat up i don't even have veins left
in my arms there's no veins if i need
blood taken i have to go to the
emergency room to have it taken because
they have to
find it like in the middle of my arm
um
so that's uh
i ended up in in uh in jail again
and
this time when i got out i had nowhere
to go and
my father offered me he said hey i had a
friend who who had a daughter that went
to florida to this halfway house did
really well
uh
if i buy you a one-way plane ticket and
pay your rent for one week what do you
say
i had nowhere else to go i said
i'm in count me in you know i got on a
plane i went to a halfway house
and uh and i stayed clean for three
years three years yeah and uh by then i
own my own business things were going
well
and back then the pill mills were open
so in florida there wasn't much heroin
but there were things called roxies
which were like oxies down there in uh
and
and dilaudid pills that you could shoot
and uh
one day i went to get a a salad at
mcdonald's for lunch
and the kid's standing in front of me i
call him a kid because i was in my 40s
now and
a lot of these people down there went
down there for rehab or whatever so
they're in their 20s or a lot younger
than me was sleeping standing up in
front of me and i had never seen that
just you know just dead asleep standing
up
and i said to them blues because that's
what they call the little blue pills
down there and he said yeah and i said
can you get more
three of my best friends had just died
within the month before
my best friend from michigan where i was
married to my first wife
shot himself in the head with my gun so
i got a call from a detective do you own
a yes i did i gave it to my friend
because i couldn't bring it to new york
oh well he killed himself with your gun
uh another friend of mine died with a
year and a half clean she just got sick
and died
she was from
uh
south florida where we live so
we were with her parents and this and
that and it was just really sad
and uh and my third friend in that short
amount of time that died killed herself
her she just went back to new york she
went down there for rehab and did well
for about a year
second she moved back to new york
started trip stripping again her mother
actually called me
and sent me a part of the suicide note
that she had written to me
um
so all that and i didn't really realize
i had no idea that my head was in a bad
spot
the kid's sleeping standing in front of
me to make a long story long
uh i thought i'd just get high once with
him and never see this kid again
i cheered the friday night meeting uh
every friday for like three years almost
and uh
and i went every single day you know to
a meeting back then
and after two weeks of trying to stop
from starting
when they asked if anybody used and they
do that at every meeting
i raised my own hand and a room of about
80 people went ah
because they really you know i was
mister i had i was doing step work i had
sponsees you know i i i was doing what
they told me to do you're not supposed
to mess up
and uh
man a second i messed up that time
i i have never had that three years back
i'll put it that way um
i'm coming up to it now uh a little bit
i uh i'm on something called gabapentin
um but that's it and it's it's a
prescription but i got there by spending
the last four years
in a methadone uh maintenance clinic
here in los angeles
um
the four years before that i came here
for rehab to la
about eight years ago
the second i got out we were getting
high
i bought a conversion van when i had
made some money
we were making money doing some dirty
stuff uh 30 sales i won't get into what
it was
uh but i could make about five grand of
sale
um and it wasn't hard to do i bought a
conversion van just in case
i had a bad month or whatever and we got
thrown out of the motel my girl and i
had a place to live so that was
you know that that was where my thinking
was at you know
and uh
and
i kept using it i couldn't stop finally
i got a decent job because the money was
running out that sort of business was
dying
that scam business whatever it's it was
a dying thing
and
so i got myself a real job downtown
on 7th street here
and uh
had to go buy a wardrobe at a goodwill
and i did that and i did what i needed
to do took the bus into work
and uh
and uh
i i tried to stop using by going to the
methadone
um
to to by getting on methadone on a detox
program well they give you two shots and
i i messed them both up i couldn't stop
while on methadone i'm still getting
high
so they offer me maintenance where they
raise your dose way up high
and you got to go every day and before
you know it you're addicted to methadone
and they take you down really slowly so
once they bring you up to a point where
the drugs don't get you high anymore
really nothing's getting you high but
the methadone keeps you feeling okay
but you'd just be wasting money if
you're spending on heroin for example
um
i got to that point so i stopped buying
heroin went to methadone every day
and i kept doing that
and slowly once i got up to a point
where i felt comfortable
went back down i'm one of very few
people that that started it and made it
i just got out like two months ago the
only drug i'm on right now like i said
is gabapentin which is a
pain reliever it slows me down a little
because i take a lot of it but you're
not using any street drugs no street
drugs for the last um the last time i
got i was just over a year ago
um i wasn't perfect while on maintenance
but
uh
i was at a point where
i felt good those were my teeth not
pills rattling in my pocket um
but uh i've been a i've been a drug
addict and
living either on the street
uh pretty much on and off for the last
20 something years you know now i have
an apartment where i live with my
girlfriend
um
our roommate doesn't know
about our past drug history by going to
methadone uh
in the morning
um
we've been able to avoid
her finding out
uh i i never uh
uh
smoked speed i couldn't stand the stuff
so i was just a straight uh straight
heroin addict um that that's my drug of
choice if maybe mix it with xanax or
something what is it about rehab that
makes it ineffective in so many cases
that makes you effective
ineffective ineffective
um
the only thing that i can say about
rehab well i can say why does so many
people relapse i guess is my question um
is because it's so easy to relapse it
really is you know all you got to do is
make the one decision one time and you
relapsed that's it when you the second
you think you could have a beer like i
thought i could have
i'd been out of rehab and clean for a
couple years
and i literally just wanted one beer
it'd been a long week a long day
the next day because i felt great from
one beer i caught a buzz i hadn't had a
drink in five years
um
the next day i bought another beer
and i didn't catch a buzz from it
so already my tolerance went that fast
on a beer
so the next day i bought a 40.
this is how i got in one week from
having a beer to to shooting heroin and
smoking crack again in one week
i bought a 40.
and now
to go home instead of taking the highway
i'm going through the inner city the
back roads
um
to go home where i can brush my teeth
when i'm done i bought some toothpaste
uh so she wouldn't smell the beer
whatever and before i know it i'm in i'm
in the bad area in new haven in
connecticut
uh where i had spent some time on the
street and i recognized somebody i know
or knew
and uh
the second i saw him it was the first
thing in my mind let's get high
and uh and i did
and and that was the start of
you know another that was the start of
eight years of in and out of jail
uh
and then i got clean for three years
like i said and then when i relapsed
then i was in and out of jail another
16 times including a two-year stint that
i did at
at one time
um
and you you sort of start getting used
to it you know what do you think
it is that makes you prone to this
addictive lifestyle is it something
genetic like somebody in your family or
was there something that happened to you
as a kid my parents were both alcoholic
um
i my parents were both also very
catholic
and
my parents had the great idea my father
was an altar boy when he was a kid him
and his two brothers
so me and my younger brother were gonna
be altar boys that was their idea you
know we went to church we did what we
were supposed to do but altar boy i
guess so mom you know but i was
relatively good kid i was 10 11 years
old
and uh
turns out uh
uh i'm just going to call it raped to
shorten what really happened as far as
the priest goes in me
um i can tell you that i can't sue
him or the catholic church because in
connecticut there is a 44-year
statute of limitations which is really
weird the uh
why there's a statute of limitations i
don't know because by the time
most people i was 39 before i mentioned
the fact that i've gotten raped by an
altar boy to anybody
39 years old and i said it in a meeting
um
i don't want my parents to know because
i think they'll blame themselves for
making me go so i never told them
but once i was able to start talking
about it in meetings
uh hopefully people can hear me talk
about it now and let people know that
look once i talked about in meetings i
couldn't believe how many people
afterwards came up to me men
and said the same [ __ ] happened to me
bro you know and
it made me feel like i wasn't on an
island of
you know you didn't know if you were gay
or
what you were because you let a man do
what he did to you when you were 10
years old you were an altar boy and he
was a priest he was the priest yeah
he's dead now he's passed away but uh
it turned out this particular priest
in connecticut before he went to the
parish where i was an altar boy
ran a boy's school
for about three years before that with a
hundred boys at it in connecticut
um
and he
had
he's a very well known i could give you
the the name right now and you can look
it up on the internet and he's a guy
that
that is well known as
uh as a priest that did a lot of damage
a lot of damage to a lot of young kids
um did he ever get caught
he did they found it they found out he
was never to my knowledge arrested
uh the catholic church
you know tonight denied that i
lost some lawsuits um
not to me uh which is fine i don't want
their money to be honest i called a a
lawyer knowing that my 44 years was up
and just offered to help if they want
help
if they want information you know
whatever
um
you know the truth is so i was an altar
boy for only three weeks my brother my
little brother and me my brother my
little brother i brought it up with him
once and he denied it like nothing
happened
so i never brought it up with him again
um
my brother is bipolar and has been on
medication since he was 21.
i don't blame
how i act today on that because it's so
long ago i've had every opportunity to
change
but
i could probably blame
what i wanted in life as a younger man
on some of that because i just wanted to
to stop whatever weird pain
i was going through internally that i
had nobody to talk to about because i
was 11 12 years old you don't talk to
the school counselor uh i wasn't in
therapy i wouldn't have trusted anybody
anyway especially after that you know
i find it to be one of the most
reprehensible
uh disgusting vile things anybody could
ever do to anybody
and i believe that i feel that way
because of what i went through
personally
i know that it's disgusting and
everything else but i what i went
through for me
was like who the who the after you tell
when you're 10 11 years old i had to
just cry and beg my mom and
don't make me go back i don't want to do
it anymore when
because i didn't want to go through that
again but i couldn't tell her
what was going on there when she sent me
there during the week you know to get
ready for sunday services it changes you
forever doesn't it it changed me forever
yeah i you know i like i said i
graduated college i owned a house i uh
when i was young you know when i got out
of school
um but when i was younger before i
graduated college you know i went to an
easy college to get through i spent the
entire time on the dead tour and would
just turn in the final assignments you
know and show up to one of the first
classes you know and just do the work
try not to fail anything
and graduate and that's what i did i
didn't go to school
you know
uh
i went to a big rolling party and did as
many drugs as i possibly could
and uh and
this goes back to the 80s we sold drugs
on the dead tour in order to support
ourselves and we made plenty of money
you know we stayed in the same hotels
that the dead stayed in
um
so we did just fine you know
as far as that went
my dad would wonder when i was in
college why i didn't come home in the
summer to get a job like everyone else
why do you never ask for money how come
you don't come home at christmas you
know we would drive from the east coast
to the new year shows out in california
and and go snowboarding on the way back
or whatever you know we we had [ __ ] to
do and we were making plenty of money
doing it i never went home spring break
on the dead tour um fall break from
college on the dead tour summer time
gone my parents were they
you know
i'll give you a quick story and then we
can probably wrap it up i'll show you
how much damage
i have caused in my own life
because of what i put myself through
in my own selfishness honestly
so
before i came back to la in
2015 i hadn't been in my parents house
for 10 years because i had stolen all my
mom's jewelry that her dead mother left
her and sold it at a pawn shop
to keep myself well
and she found out obviously
i hadn't been in her house in 10 years
and i loved my mother to death she was
never mean to me never a bad mother
so 10 years goes by
and i'm to the point where i'm doing
okay
and i'm supposed to go home for
thanksgiving to my parents house for
thanksgiving hadn't been in connecticut
in 10 years
so i do that and uh
and i'm sneaking around
a little bit getting enough to be okay
i went there with a little bit of a
habit when i talked to my parents about
going i didn't have a habit i thought
i'd be okay
and i wasn't and
so thanksgiving my brother has
thanksgiving at his house
and
when i had the opportunity i grabbed
three little pieces of gold
uh from his upstairs that turned out to
be his daughter's earrings
uh
his
current wife still
who does not care for me very much
told the police that they were all
tiffany earrings so what i got a hundred
bucks for i got three charges of three
thousand dollars each felony theft
uh in connecticut for
um
and i have not been back to my parents
house since and i don't expect to be
invited back there ever again
um
my father was like
why didn't you just tell me he was
literally like face to face why didn't
you just tell me that you needed some
help
and instead i chose the addict's way
of trying to sneak something and
beat the system
and i've talked to my brother twice now
in in uh eight years
after that you know i almost ruined my
mother's relationship with my brother's
children they're both special needs
girls my mother takes care of them three
times a week
picks them up from school takes them all
over the place at 79 years old they are
her life and because of the choices that
i made
my brother's wife is like they're not in
her life anymore i mean it was
you know my mother
was done talking to me for a while
because of that
and my father just
would keep in contact with me to make
sure i was still alive but
at that point that was about all he
cared about you know to be able to
report to
maybe for himself i don't know
or to my mom that i'm still alive um i'm
working on that relationship now the
methadone maintenance part of that
was a big deal for them that i got
through it and actually was
like three percent one or three percent
that finishes that
um
so it's important to me to stay clean
that's why i still have some dangerous
friends that i hang around with i don't
spend that much time with him
uh anymore
um uh billy and i
uh
my good friend billy who you happen to
know i say like everybody knows him but
he's a good friend of mine
uh spent a lot of time living off of
whatever money crazy money he made or
crazy money i made in hotel rooms
spending it all on drugs and we would
just
live that way we lived that way as often
as we could
and looking back now
it was just years
years of using living on the street or
living in a motel room
and uh
and just bad choices you know the the
truth is
rehab gives you the opportunity
to put some distance and time
between how you're acting
which gets you things like jail in
prison
uh and ruins relationships with people
you love like your mom
put some time between that person and
the person that you either used to be or
the person that you want to be and you
know you can't be and everybody can stop
but you can't stop if you stay where you
were how many how much time do you
recommend
of rehab
as much as they'll give you
i heard somebody heard someone tell me
yesterday every it's got to be at least
a year and a half the longer that you
stay in
you know uh
the longer people have when they get out
of not using
if you can stand for a year if that's
possible stay in for a year everybody
wants to leave a week after they get in
i don't know why
i know why because they want to go out
and get high but i don't know why you
know if you can stay there for a month
and start making friends and it's not
you're the brand new guy still [ __ ]
yourself and you can't sleep and what
you know
what it's like in the beginning
it's not like that anymore in about a
month
if they'll keep you depending on your
where you went or your insurance or
whatever you know there's some state-run
state-funded programs in la that will do
six and nine-month programs which is
wonderful do it do as much as you can
the more time you can put between like i
said how you're acting and how you want
to act the better off you are
the more of those people that went away
or you know are in a different hotel
room now or you won't be able to find
them
f facebook you know you don't need to
find these people you don't need to not
if you unless you want them back in your
life
i don't go on facebook
um i stop you know you either
see all your friends that are dying or
you you bump into people that you would
love to see because
you want to go out and screw around uh
and it's real easy by calling
bob the guy used to get high with or
whatever
um
that's you know that's it man that's you
know right now i consider myself lucky
i've got if you can you see the scars on
my legs
yeah you can tell that
um
this is from
black heroin in uh in california about
six years ago i shot dope in my legs i'd
like i said i was running out of veins
so i got these crazy scars
uh wherever i can still have them i
guess you don't see them as bad anymore
and i got an infection in my legs
somehow and they it was staying under my
knees
i was trying to keep them clean
my girlfriend at the time begged me to
go to the emergency room i finally went
i waited six hours to see somebody and i
was in too much pain so i left
and uh and i went and got high and she
made me go back the next day
the doctor when he finally strapped me
to a bed said
if i had waited another week he said
there was a really good chance that i
would have had to cut your legs off
maybe if you're lucky below your knee
but probably above your knee to stay
safe and you'd be in a wheelchair or
walking around on nubs for the rest of
your life i was a week away from that
and uh
um
thank god i still have my legs
uh i don't really have any any veins
like i said on the on the outsides of my
hands my arms
uh in here they're just gone they're
flat i can't shoot dope obviously if i
wanted to in my legs i don't want to
anymore but it takes a lot and you know
what this didn't get me to stop
you know when i was in there i had my
drug dealer they they had to put a thing
called a pick even losing your legs
didn't get you to stop even i had my
drug dealer bringing them
bringing the drugs to the room i was in
the hospital the threat of losing
yourself i would mix it and put it into
it i had still yeah it was that bad the
thought of losing my legs didn't get me
to stop
i still wanted to get high it's amazing
sean what would you say is the most
important lesson you learned from all of
this
uh
i'm 54 years old
i've had every opportunity in life
handed to me and i've messed most of
them up
the lesson that i learned is
that
the only person you can really rely on
in this world is yourself
you can't rely on family
you can't you know even if you want to
some people feel like they can maybe
their family helps them financially
that's not relying on somebody that's
relying on their money
um
if you need friends go to an a meeting
those people need friends too
and they'll be happy to be yours as long
as you're not getting high and if you
are you can find people doing that there
too if that's what you want to do
but you'll find the ones that aren't
using
real fast you'll see the ones that are
there every day you'll be able to tell
by how people speak which ones are there
living the lifestyle that they
claim to live and want to live and in a
short period of time
um
you can have any life you want and i
don't care if you're digging ditches
again or painting houses with a college
degree
you know uh
it doesn't matter you know you can you
can pay your own bills you can all of a
sudden own a truck again
uh a motorcycle that i can barely ride
anymore because i'm too old it takes all
the wind out of me riding a dirt bike
but uh but you can have all those things
back
uh if you want them but
you can't have them with drugs you
cannot have them with drugs and that's
i'm not
saying that that's my experience
that's what i've seen on the street
every day
for
almost 40 years
and
uh that's the life that i got to live i
had the choice of getting out of two
years in jail and not getting high and i
got high that's how stupid you can be
that's how much they call you
anybody that offers your hand man offers
you a hand to help you
take their hand
you know just all you got to do is reach
back man it ain't that hard
you know but they're not going to give
you money they're not going to give you
a place to live they're going to give
you support
they'll give you friendship
call me in the middle of the night if
you feel like you're going to get high
that's the kind of help that you'll get
if you're looking for more help than
that
go sign up for
you know disability or something you
know and move into section 8 housing but
that's the life that you're going to end
up with you still have the opportunity
to have any life you want unless
they had cut my legs off already and i
was stuck there which i came real close
to
but uh
again that was my stupid bad choices and
i just got really lucky
super lucky man i consider myself
i'm not i'm not a god guy i consider
myself a super super lucky person
but i'm not afraid of death
you know
why would i be you know i i
i've cheated death so many times
that the day that i don't
oh well right i
at least to me that's the way i feel
about it and if you've gone through
five years of being on the street in
heroin addict you'll know exactly what
i'm talking about
and if you've gone through 40 years of
being on the street being a heroin
addict
you'll definitely know what i'm talking
about
because that's just it man like every
single day is a blessing i shouldn't
have it i shouldn't be here
i don't look at facebook anymore because
once a week i see another dead friend
that i went to rehab with or
i was in jail with or whatever
um
anyway so
i've got a good girl in my life today
who supports me like you wouldn't
believe she's in nursing school
and working so she's
65 hours a week plus cleans the house
and picks up my dirty laundry and stuff
i don't deserve you know but i have it
because i don't use anymore
otherwise i
i'd be living in a tent right now and
i've been there enough to
to know how easy it is to go back to
i'm one decision away from it that's it
man sean thank you so much for sharing
your story appreciate the time that's
nice truly mark thank you so much
you